let's update you about what's going on
on the Democratic side last week I told
you that polling in Nevada and South
Carolina the next two Democratic primary
states had Hillary Clinton well ahead in
both up 20 points in Nevada but we were
aware that we didn't really have recent
polling from Nevada last week I got a
ton of emails over the weekend saying
David there is a new poll in Nevada and
Bernie Sanders is tied with Hillary
Clinton in Nevada and I said I have to
see this this cannot be true and it is
true there is a poll that has Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton tied in the
upcoming Nevada primary but the pole is
from the Washington free beacon and
target point consulting both right-wing
organizations why would it matter though
they're just polling Democrats well if
you believe that the Democratic that out
that the Republican Party wants Bernie
to be the Democratic nominee because
they think it will be easier for a
Republican to defeat Bernie than it
would be to defeat Hillary then you
could suggest that right-wing pollsters
would have an interest in making it seem
as though bernie is more viable than he
is but what really matters is the
methodology that's where the truth is
and when we looked at the methodology
Louis we found there was a sample size
of 1236 which is perfect we saw a margin
of error plus or minus three percent
which makes sense this poll included all
registered voters two-thirds of whom
responded that they are definitely
voting forty-five percent of which have
caucused in the past so reasonable I
mean a reasonable model and distribution
of who is included in this poll the poll
did have both negative Hillary and
negative Bernie questions like for
example would you vote for Hillary
Clinton in spite of the fact that she
would kill babies if given the
opportunity right they throw in these
negative questions but those were after
just asking who would you vote for and
there were no negative questions about
Bernie as well so that made me think
this does seem like a pretty legit pole
and then Nate Silver's
fivethirtyeight.com said based on their
analysis there is a 50-50 shot for each
candidate in Nevada so Louis it looks
like Nevada is now
how very much in play feels like
Groundhog's Day state after state we say
hey Hillary's got this one maybe she
doesn't maybe she doesn't people are
feeling the burn well what other
explanation is there Dave the feeling
the burn I don't think there is uh much
of another explanation there no question
about it gamefly is sort of like Netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one xbox 360
ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low use price there's
never any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s